[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ولد ضيفنا في محافظه المنيا في
الصعيد الاوسط بمصر عام
1943 لابي شاعر فصيح رغم عدم كونه متعلما
متصوف محب للجميع كما يقول ابنه اذا كان
ضيفنا الدكتور سعد عبد العزيز مصلوح استاذ
اللسانيات على خطى ابيه متصالحا مع الجميع
منفتحا على كل التيارات الدكتور مصلوح
اشبه بشيخ طريقه له يريدون كثر محبون
لطالما تلقيت منهم الرسائل التي تدعو
لاستضافته بالحاح شديد في المقابله محب
للغه حصل على ليسانس من كليه دار العلوم
عام 63 ونال منها ايضا درجه الماجستير بعد
النكسه بعام واحد في دراسه صوتيه للهجات
اهل المنيا في مصر في ضوء الجغرافيا
اللغويه ومنها كانت الانتقاله الى معقل
الشيوعيه موسكو لينال من هناك شهاده
الدكتوراه في اللسانيات متخصصا في
الصوتيات المختبريه من معهد بلدان اسيا
وافريقيا بالجامعه وقد كان من اوائل من
ادخلوا اللسانيات والاسلوبيه الاحصائيه
كتخصص ضمن علوم اللغه له من المؤلفات
سلسله التفصيل في اعراب ايات التنزيل في
سته عشر مجددا بالمشاركه مع اخرين وحركات
التجديد في موسيقى الشعر العربي الحديث في
البلاغه العربيه والاسلوبيات اللسانيه
وغيرها من الكتب المختصه باللغه
واللسانيات وما يتفرع عنها اضافه للترجمات
الكثيره والمتنوعه مشاهدينا الكرام
الاكاديميه والمصري الدكتور سعد مصلوح
استاذ اللسانيات الخبير في اللغه ضيف
المقابله فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
دكتور سعد مصلح انا سعيد جدا بوجودك
المثقف الاكاديمي واستاذ اللسانيات وعضو
المجمع اللغوي الليبي ايضا والاستاذ في
عدد من الجامعات العربيه سابقا الحقيقه
انا اكثر سعاده
لاني من متابعي هذا البرنامج الرصين جدا
بالشخصيات التي تستضاف وبطريقه الحوار
الذكيه التي تستخرج من الضيف يعني احسن ما
عنده ما سر مريديكم ومحبيك كثر السر هو
ستر الله
نعود دكتور للبدايات انت ولدت في محافظه
المنيا نعم في الصعيد الادنى
الاوسط الاوسط وليس الادنى انا كنت اقول
لهم ان هناك يعني ثلاث
ثلاثه
صعدة
نستفيد منها بس لغويه
ذكرت في القران
صعيدا زلق وصعيدا جرزه وصعيدا طيبه
فالصعيدا زلق هذا الذي بجوار القاهره كاد
ان يسلق فيصير من اهل الوجه البحري
والصعيد الجرس هو الصعيد الاقصى اما
المنيا فهي الصعيد الطيب الصعيد الطيب
في اي اسره نشات
اسره بسيطه جدا جدا
اسره ريفيه الوالد رحمه الله
اشتغل بالفلاحه مثل اهل البلاد
لكنه يعني كانت له رؤيه
جميله جدا جدا
اغرم بالعلم ولم يغرم بالشهادات
فانا محبا للعلم وللتعلم وكان يعني
يعني لا يحترم الشهادات كثيره في وقت كانت
الشهاده يعني
اهميه
ولكنه كان يقول يعني من شعره الجميل كان
شاعرا فصيلا نعم شاعرا ومترجما للشعر الى
شعر ايضا هل تعلم لا ابدا ولا التعليم
الكتاب
اه نعم لكنه لم لم يدخل في المدارس في
التعليم الرسمي لم يدخل فكان يقول وكم من
قافز بمؤهلات
ثقافته مكفنه بهن الله وكم من قافز
بمؤهلاته ثقافته مكفنه بهنه مكفنه بهن
بالمؤه بالمؤهلات وما اغنى المؤهل عنه
شيئا اذا معه حشرنا وامتحنه الله كان
شاعرا جميلا شعرا رائع يعني اخذت منه هذا
الحمد لله انا الوحيد من بين اخواتي
كتبت المقالات صغيره في عمر اين درست في
البدايه
في البدايه درسنا في المدرسه الابتدائيه
في مصر في المنيا نعم
وثم انتقلت الى التعليم الاعدادي المتوسط
يعني ثم التعليم الثانوي كل هذا في المنيا
تفوته الحمد لله نعم كنت الحمد لله لان
كان في عنايه في البيت في البيت يعني
شديده جدا من الوالد من الوالد رحمه ماذا
اخذت ماذا نقلت من الشيخ عبد العزيز مصباح
نقلت منه حب اللغه العربيه
وهو حب لا يزال يلابسني
وسيظل باذن الله الى ان هذا الدكتور كان
استثناء في ذلك الوقت ام قاعده عامه لانه
يعني ما بعد عصر النهضه العربي على الاقل
سرى صار اهتمام الاهتمام هو بطبيعه الحال
الوالد اكتشف شاعريته
مبكرا
فاتجهت البوصله الى هذا
يحل للعرب الاوائل الذين يقولون الشعر
الفصيح بقواعده بجماله دون ان يرتبط ذلك
بالتعليم لا هو لا التعليم الرسمي لا لكنه
كان مثقفا بمعنى الكلمه وله مجموعه شهريه
طبعت سنه 29 تقريبا اسمها العلم السعدي
نسبه الى سعد زغلول وفي الشخصيه البارزه
وفي هذا الديوان
وضع خطابا مفتوحا الى الملك فؤاد الاول
يطالبه فيه
بحقوق الفلاحين
وبالوضع البائس للفلاح المصري
وكان خطابا جريئا جدا جدا في ذلك الوقت
كان مؤسسا لجمعيه سماها جمعيه انصار الحق
في منسفيس منسفيس هذه قريه جمعيه سياسيه
ولا ايش الترجمه الجمعيه اجتماعيه ولكن
يساند فيها الفلاحين في مشكلاتهم مع كبار
الملاك في ذلك الوقت
وكتب هذا الكتاب الى الملك فؤاد الاول
بهذه الصفه رئيس جمعيه انصار الحق وهو
الكتاب مطبوع في سنه 29 كنت وفديا على على
هديه على بدات كذلك وماذا انتهيت
كنت وفديا الى ان توفي سراج الدين
لان هذا هو الشخصيه
التاريخيه نعم الجاذبه يعني انت نشات على
على جفوه بينك وبين الثوره نعم الى حد
كبير وقد كان هذا يعني من ضمن
القصص الطريفه انني وانا عندي حوالي 12
عاما كتبت مقالا في جريده اقليميه تصدر في
المانيا
كان اربعه وخمسين
اللي هي بدايه الانفكاك بين
المناخ
الليبرالي الديمقراطي السابقه الملكيه
ماذا كان ماذا كان فحوى فحوى المقال انني
تصورت سفينه تسير في البحر وسط الامواج
وكان التسيير فيها هدوء وسلام ثم قام بعض
الركاب من خلاب على قاده السفينه وزعموا
انها تطير الى مستقبل مجهول
ماذا فعلوا
اشياء التصرف انا استدعيت
للنيابه الصحافه
لانه ظنوا ان الذي كتبنا قال هو الوالد
وانه كتب باسمك
عندنا مصيبه جديده مصيبه اخرى ما كانوا
يتوقعون
حققوا معك
حققوا معي
طبعا رمزيه المقر كانت واضحه كانت واضحه
ولكنني زعمت
عندما تهب العواصف من كل جهه في بعض
الاحيان لا تدرك لا تستطيع تحدد لك موقعا
معينا يعني يعني انا كواردي مقدس الحريه
ومن المنيا والقاهره ومصر الى موسكو نعم
هناك دراسه الماجستير والدكتوره ولا
الماجستير في جامعه القاهره نعم كل الدار
لها مكانه ولهاسمت هذا نعم
اتجهت الى موسكو لماذا كان موسكو توفرت
بعثه مثلا
نحن عندما تخرجنا كنا في سنوات يسمونها
سنوات التحول الاشتراكي
وضيق على البعثات تضيقا شديدا واصبحت
محدوده بحكم الاعباء الماليه
وكانوا لا يرون لهذا الامر يعني اهميه
كبرى كبرى
والذي حدث ان موسكو عرضت عددا من المنح
الدراسيه
فعرضوا علي المنحه وقبلت درست اللسانيات
في جامعه موسكو درجه الدكتوراه في موضوع
محدد نعم وهو موضوع كان يعني هو البرزخ
الذي عبرت منه من اللغه الى الادب كيف انا
تخصصي اصلا كان
الصوتيات مختبريه قرات هذا تعرف نحن ننجح
لهذا الامر
هذه مساله فنيه تقنيه نعم
الفحص المختبري للاصوات سواء كان فحص
النطق او فحص
الموجات الصوتيه يعني
اخترت موضوعا كان يشغلني وانا في الثانويه
العامه
وهو لماذا في القافيه العربيه هناك انماط
تكون مسموح بها وانماط يكون
غير مسموح به
توجهت الى محاوله كشف الاسس
الفيزيائيه
التي تحكم عمليه المنح والسماع ثم تقواعد
فيزيائيه طبعا طبعا يعني لماذا مثلا في
القافيه العربيه
تتبادل الالف المديه والياء المد الواو
الماديه والياء الماديه لكن لا تتبادلني
مع الالف الماديه يعني تقول مثلا
الا ليت ايام الصفاء جديد ودهرا تولى يا
بثينه يعود لكن يعادوا لا تاتي في هذا
السياق هذه الاسئله واشياء اخرى يعني كانت
تشغلني ان تتحدثت عن الوالد كثيرا من شعرك
اريد ان استمع الى شيء اذكر قصيده كتبتها
سنه 59
لا تبرحه
يعني ذاكره ذاكرتك كانت لحظه احسست فيها
بمنتهى
الالم نظرا للاغتراب والسن الصغير وظروف
الحياه الماديه ايضا
مع لذه
الهدف الذي اسعى اليه وانا في
الفقره الاولى في دار العلوم
فلحظه امتزاج هذه كانت لحظه فريده جدا ولم
تدم غير ثوان
لكني
التقطتها وثبتتها فقلت هذه الابيات
وتفقت امضي والنوازل ترتمي مسعوره
وغذاءهن دماء
امضي ومن حولي ومن حولي ترف اجائر هي جت
لهن الورقاء واذا بنفسي بعد طول تكدر تصفو
وتسخر من جحيم عنائي
وتزاحم الاشواك في فجواتها بازائر رفافه
الانباء والصاب تمزجه بشهد رضابها والليله
تخلقه بفجر ضيائي كان الصباح قد الهم
لناظري والان
فاستضى مسائي الله سلمت سلمت انا سعيد جدا
بالمثقف الاديب والاكاديم الدكتور سعد
مصلوح والى طاوله الحوار مرحبا اهلا مرحبا
بك
[موسيقى]
تفاعلات فكريه لا تهدا وقبله للدارسين
والمثقفين العرب كان هذا هو حال مصر خلال
القرن الماضي لا سيما خلال عقدي
الاربعينات
تتويجا لنشاط كبير في حركه الكتابه والنشر
والترجمه بدات منذ منتصف القرن التاسع عشر
ورسخ مكانه القاهره كاحد مركزين للثقافه
العربيه بينما لم يكن المركز الاخر سوى
بيروت
عني مثقف ذلك الوقت بالحركه الفكريه
والادبيه الاوروبيه فقراوا ووثقوا
واختاروا الاعمال المراده ترجمتها وحاولوا
من خلال التقارير والملخصات وترجمات
الاعمال الغربيه الكبيره نشر فكر الاخرين
بعد قرون من الانغلاق على الذات
اثمر الغوص في اداب الغرب الوانا وصلوفا
ادبيه لم تكن معهوده في الادب العربي
فتعددت المجلات التي توثق للحاله الثقافيه
وتورد نتاج الادباء وتبرز تطلعات الوثق
فيه شهدت هذه الفتره اقبالا واسعا من
الشباب على دراسه علوم اللغه العربيه
وادابها بفعل الحركه الفكريه النشطه الى
جانب القامات التي اثرت الميدان الادبيه
والثقافي بمن توجها النوعي الغزير
لماذا اهتممت بهذا الامر وبهذه الزاويه
الفنيه الدقيقه انا مغرم جدا بالقافيه منذ
صبايا الباكر
وما زلت مغرما بها وحتى في شعري انا اتوخى
عاده ان اكتب مما يسمونه
القوافي النفر يعني غير الشائعه مثل يعني
اكتب على الذال وعلى جاي وعلى الثاء وعلى
الجيم ثم تقوى في شائعه واخرى غير شامله
نعم هناك تقريبا ابو العلاء الماري
صنف القافيه الى ثلاثه
انواع
ما سماه القوافي النفر وهي القليله الشيوع
والنادره قافيه مثل الظاء مثلا لا تجد
عليها شعرا الذال قليله جدا جدا الصاد
ايضا قليل قليله جدا جدا ثم
في مرتبه الثانيه تاتي القوافي الحوش التي
هي وسط بين النفور والذيوع الحوش اه نعم
ثم القوافذ الذلل التي يكتب فيها المذلل
اذا النفر والحوش والذلل والذلل نعم
فانا عاده كنت يعني بين النفر والحوش
فكانت قضايا القافيه تشغلني منذ كنت ارود
الشعر وانا في يعني اقصد يعني وظفت شعريتك
وكونك شاعر واهتمامك بالشعر في مساله ايضا
التخصص الدقيق ومحاوله فهمه والتاصيل له
انا اتجهت بتكوين كله الى هذا الموضوع
وكان هذا الموضوع هو المجاز الذي عبر به
من تخصص الصوتيات المحض الى
تعالق الظاهره الصوتيه في اللغه مع الشعر
والادب كنت اول من ادخلوا اللسانيات
والاسلوبيه احصائيه ضمن علوم اللغه متى
كان ذلك وكيف تم
عدي من الجيل الثاني ليس من الجيل الاول
الجيل الاول هم اساتذتنا الذين ذهبوا الى
بريطانيا في
اواخر الاربعينيات
وعادوا في وسط الخمسينيات انا تتلمست على
الجيل الثاني
وكانت مشكله لان التتلمذ على الجيل الثاني
كان يضيق واسعا جدا جدا كل الجيل الاول
تتلمذ على استاذ واحد في جامعه واحده
هو
الاستاذ
درجنا على ان علم اللغه هو
حصل تماهي بين بين فرث ولا لغه بين فرث
كعلم
الصدمه
الثانيه انني عندما بدات اقرا بالروسيه
تبين لي ان فيرس هو نغمه في سيمفونيه
معقده جدا جدا
ولا تشكل حتى يعني ابرز هذه الاتجاهات
فحدث انفتاح لغوي مع الانفتاح القرائي على
المشهد اللساني بوجه عام ماذا اكتشفته في
المشهد اللساني حينما درست بالرصيد
واكتشفت ان
المدرسه الواحده لا تستقل
بالاسهام في حل مشكلات اللغه العربيه
واكتشفت ايضا عالما من اللسانيات الشرقيه
التي كان محظورا علينا تقريبا ان نتعرف
اليها بماذا تنشغل اللسانيات دكتور كتخصص
يعني لغير المختصين لغير العارفين وانا
منهم
مكانه اللسانيات في العلوم اعتقد وانا
يعني ازعم ذلك ان مكانتها في العلم
المعاصر هي مكانه الفلسفه في العلوم
القديمه
يعني
لسانيات الان
تتبوا
المقعد
التخصص الام الذي ان شعبت منه تخصصات هذا
اللافت بالنسبه لي من معرفه عامه وليست
معرفه تخصصي ان الفلسفه سابقا كانت هي ام
العلوم وبالتالي نحن نحصل على الفلسفه في
التربيه الفلسفه في الادب الفلسفه ثم جاء
جيل اللسانيات اليوم او اساتذه الساريات
او المختصين ومن كتبوا في يكتبون في قضايا
كثيره وكانهم مفتاح
ومؤسس للفكر بشكل عام لان موضوعهم هو
اللسان
واللسان هو وعاء الفكر
[موسيقى]
الاتجاهات
العلميه والمعرفيه ما مدى تاثير الشرق
وانت اتجهت شرقا الى الاتحاد السوفيتي في
تلك الفتره وكانت العلوم معظمها وكانت
المعرفه معظمها يعني مرتبطه بالغرب وحيدته
والليبراليه الغربيه وما الى ذلك هذا هو
ما شجعني على الاتجاه شرقا
يعني كنت اتطلع الى
مناخ معرفيا مختلف
وان كنت وان كان ذلك يعني صاحبه كثير من
التهيب وكثير من التردد في اول الامر
بحكم ما هو شاهد بحكم هيمنه
التوجهات الغربيه على مجمل المشهد الثقافي
ليس ليس لسانيات فقط على مجمل المشهد
بماذا عدت من موسكو للاتحاد السوفيتي
والله الحمد لله عدت بكثير اولا انا كان
موضوعي في الصوتيات المختبريه
فكان موضوعا بعيدا جدا عن مجال
الايدولوجيا
فتركت مجال الاديولوجيا لقراءه الخاصه من
هذا اسال عنك يعني انت في معقل
الايديولوجيا
يعني في حقبه برج نيف الذي الايدولوجيا في
في اوجاع قيمتها وفرضوا علينا ايضا هناك
لكي تحصل على الدكتوراه ان تدرس الماركسيه
اللينيه
ودرستها بحمد الله لكنك لكنها لم تتغلغل
الى داخلك بالعكس الذي حدث انني كنت كانت
دفعتي تتكون تقريبا من 35 دارسا
من المصريين في المجموعه التي كنا ندرس
فيها وكنت بحمد الله الاول على هذه
المجموعه ماذا تركت العلامه الكامله
الماركسيه اللينيه فكرا ايدولوجيا موقفا
فهما
مؤسسه ليست سطحيه او هامشيه هو انت لا
تعدم في الفكر المادي في الفكر المادي
الجدلي كثيرا من
من مبادئ التاسيس المعرفي المشكله عندما
تنتقل الماديه الجدليه الى
الماديه التاريخيه
هنا يعني تتغول الايديولوجيا والسياسه على
علي وانا
ذهبت وانا يعني حاصل على الماجستير وعقلي
الى حد كبير محصن وبالتالي مؤسس بشكل جيد
على التاثر الكبير على على الانقياد
انما التاثر بشكل ما حاولت ان يكون
ايجابيه لم تنحز لم تذهب يسارا قليلا
اطلاقا اطلاقا
موقف طريف للجنه
لجنه
الامتحان في المركزيه الجذريه كان يراسها
رجل عجوز
ويعني مؤسس فكان يلاحظ قال لي انت دائما
تقول لي في اجابتك تقول الماركسيه
الليلانيه وفي راي وفي راي ماركس كذا راي
انجلوس كذا فما رايك انت
فبغتني بهذا السؤال
ولم اريد ان اكذب ولم اريد ان اصدق ايضا
منزله ما بين المنزلتين الموقع السؤال
مباغت والموقف محرج هو يعرف ماذا تنقل
وبالتالي يريد ان يعرف ماذا تؤمن
فقلت له انا الان في مرحله التفكير
لم احسم امري بعد
فسر قبل منك
الاجابه واعطاني رقم هاتفه لكي استشيره
يعني فيما يبدو لي حتى يدفعك الى مزيد من
الايمان حتى ادفعك للحسم
الحمد لله يعني
[موسيقى]
المشهد مختلط الى حد كبير
بوجه عام المنحنى ينحدر سواء في نواياه
الطالب او حتى في نوعيه
الاساتذه اعضاء هيئه التدريس بل ايضا في
نوعيه الاهتمامات
لان
نشا جيل يلهث وراء الشهاده
اصبحت الشهاده هي الهدف هي الهدف هي
الغايه بذاتها وقد ورثت عن ابي
ما ذكرته لنا ذكرته لك ان الشهاده ليست هي
كل شيء
وبالفعل
حاولت حتى اني انهيت رسالتي للماجستير
انهيتها لكن انتظرت استاذا كان معارا
الاستاذ الذي اعتقد انه يفهم هذا العمل
ويوجه توجيه سديدا انتظرته عاما كاملا
لكي يعود من الاعاره ويناقشني في عملت في
السعوديه في فتره مهمه كانت كانت ثمه
معركه وجدال بين الحدثين ومدرسه التقليديه
ويعني اسهمت اشتبكت مع المجال الثقافي
الادبي هناك
والذي حدث انني عملت في جامعه الملك عبد
العزيز في الفتره ما بين
1978 و1982
في 1979
رجع الاخ الصديق الدكتور عبد الله الغزامي
من بعثته كنت اقدم منه في القسم بعام
وتزاملنا في هذه الفتره لم يكن الدكتور
عبد الله في ذلك الوقت مهتما بقضيه
الحداثه لكن
التطور الطبيعي لداعيات المشهد لك محاضره
شهيره لحسين
في في نادي جده الادبي هذه كانت محاضره
مشهوده حضرها
الدكتور حسين مؤنس كان في زياره للمملكه
يدرس في معهد الدبلوماسيين
وسمع بالمحاضره فاتى ما موضوعها ولماذا
كانت محاضره ذات اهميه كبرى اهميتها انها
ادخلت البعد اللساني على مسار النقد
الادبي
وحولت النظر من المناهج الخارجيه لدراسه
الادب علاقه النص بالمجتمع علاقه النص
بالتاريخ علاقه النص بنفسيه
[موسيقى]
الاديب علاقه النص بالقيم
السائده القيم الدينيه كل هذا الى التركيز
على النص نفسه بعيدا عن ما يحيط به
يعني ليس بعيدا ولكن اصبح
النص هو في مقدمه
المشهد
والمعركه الثقافيه كانت في الاتجاه الاخر
ودللت في الطب المجتمع بالدين بالثقافه
السائده بالموروث بكل ذلك وهذا كان مهب
الريح عاده يعني
وهذا اكثر متعه وجدليه اكثر متعه وجدليه
نعم اعلاميا صحفيا اجتماعي لكن انا يعني
توجهت وجهه معينه
لخصتها في عباره وضعتها في كتاب لي صدر
سنه 1980 وانا في السعوديه
قلت ان الادب فن ولكن دراسه الادب ينبغي
ان تكون علما
[موسيقى]
النصف الاول من القرن الماضي يقترن بنهضه
كبرى في الاهتمام باللغه العربيه فتبرز
الحاجه الى انشاء مجامع لها خدمه لعلومها
وادابها ولسان الناطقين بها
كانت البدايه بانشاء مجمع للغه العربيه في
دمشق عام
1919 ثم بيروت عام 1927 فالقاهره في عام
32 وبغداد عام 47 ليتوج ذلك كله بتاسيس
اتحاد المجامع اللغويه العلميه العربيه في
القاهره عام
1971 برئاسه الدكتور طه حسين
اخذ الاتحاد على عاتقه تنسيق الجهود بين
المجامع المختلفه الى جانب العمل على
توحيد المصطلحات العلميه والفنيه
والحضاريه التي تقرها المجامع المختلفه
فضلا عن وضع المشروعات التي تحقق اهدافه
خرجت عن المجامع اللغويه في الحواضر
العربيه توصيات عده كان ابرزها توصيه
للحكومات باتخاذ قرارات سياسيه تمكن
الفصحى من اخذ مكانتها والى التعريب
الاهتمام اللازم لكنها توصيات لم تعدو ان
تكون حبرا على ورق
اريد ان انتقل لمحور جديد دكتور سعد مصلوح
يتعلق باللغه ويتعلق بالمجامع اللغويه
ويتعلق بحال العربيه وحال وانت متخصص فيها
بشكل كبير اولا ما تقييمك لحال اللغه
العربيه اليوم في عالمنا العربي استخداما
وتوظيفا وتطورا
واتقانا ومعرفه وعلما وما الى ذلك هو يعني
هذا
عندي انطباع
يمتزج فيه
يعني
الانطباع السلبي بالانطباع الايجابي انا
ارى ان اللغه الان في حاله ازمه بكل تاكيد
من حيث ان اولياء الامور لا يشجعون
ابنائهم على معرفه العربيه وعلى التزود من
من ثقافتها
السوق العمل تلح على اللغه الاهميه اللغه
الاجنبيه وامور اخرى كثيره
برضو ايضا مستوى التعليم يعني بوجه عام في
العالم العربي
لغه واستخداما انها اللغه لا تعين على لا
تعين
من يستخدمها في في المجالات الجديده
التقنيه والتكنولوجيا وكذا انها عاجزه
نوعا ما هل هذا اتهام دقيق في محله هذا
غير صحيح ولقد سالتني سؤالا
القيت فيه محاضره منذ
اسابيع قليله
عنوان المحاضره صعوبه العربيه حقيقه ام
وهم
نفس هذا ما رايك بهذا
في هذه طبعا
الصعوبه مفهوم رجراج يعني مفهوم ليس
مفهومه يمكن يعني ضبطه
لكن انت
فرق بين ان ترجع صعوبه الى طبيعه اللغه
نفسها هذا شيء والى مشكلات تعليمها
هذا شيء اخر والى الموقف المجتمعي من
اللغه
يعني انا عندي ثلاثه
مقاربات لموضوع الاول اللغه هل النظام او
النسق القواعد في اللغه
نسق صعب ومعقد
وغير متاح
للتلقي والاستقبال انا جعلت المحاضره لان
الجانب الاخر الا التعليم هذا اختصاصه
التربويين
العاملين في معرفتك في اللغات تسمح لك بان
تجيب هنا
انك تجيب على الجانب اللغوي اللغوي نعم
فعلا حاولت
وارجع انني نجحت
ان اثبت ان اللغه العربيه
نظامها نظام
منطقي جدا
ويسير جدا وان في اللغات الاخرى ما هو
اعقد وضربت مثلا باللغه الاخرى التي
اعرفها جيدا وهي الروسيه يعني مثلا ضربته
مثلا بان حالات الاعراب في اللغه العربيه
ثلاثه في الروسيه ست حالات وبالتالي اكثر
تعقيدا بالتالي اكثر تعقيدا ضربته مثلا
بان الصفه والموصوف في اللغه العربيه من
التوابع لكنها في اللغه الروسيه ليست من
التوابع الصفه تتصرف بطريقه في الست حالات
والموصوف يتصرفه في كل حاله من حالات
اللغوي الجهاز القواعد نفسه ليس في اللغه
العربيه ليس نظاما صعبا بس ضربت مثل بلغه
ايضا لم تنتشر الروسيه لم لم تجد رواجا
مثل الانجليزيه
قد لا تجد رواجا في عالمنا لظروف سياسيه
وتاريخيه لكنها لغه يتكلم بها عدد كبير من
ملايين من الناس وانا ضربت مثلا بنفسي في
تلقيها انت تعلمتها وانت كبير
يعني هل كانت صعبه علي طيب ما في مقاربه
مع الانجليزيه
لبحث يعني اظنه بحث مهم ومن الاوليات ايضا
عن قرينه الرتبه بين العربيه والانجليزيه
والروسيه
في حل انجليزيه الامر ايسر ولا اكثر
تعقيده من في حاله
المشكله ان اللغه العربيه لغه تنتمي الى
ما يسمونه لغات النسق الحر
الذي يحتفظ بعلامات اعرابيه تدل على
الوظيفه اللغويه يعني الرفع علامه
الفاعليه النصب علامه المفعوليه الجر
علامه الاضافه فهناك علامات ملفوظه تحدد
الوظائف النحويه ومن هنا تستطيع ان تقدم
او تؤخر في الجمله العربيه وتظل الوظيفه
ذاته مثل المبتدا المؤخر الخبر المقدم
تقديم الخبر تقديم الفاعل وانت مثلا تقول
في اللغه العربيه فريقا كذبتم وفريقا
تقتلون
تقول ولقد جاء ال لوطن المرسلون
في قدمت المفعول بين بين الفعل في مرور
مرونه كبيره انجليزيه هذا الامر موجود غير
موجود غير موجود غير موجود لانها تبدو
اسهل يعني من حيث الشكل اقصد من حيث
الفكره الرائجه كانه الانجليزيه اسهل
ربما تكون الانجليزيه اسهل لكن الانجليزيه
تفتقد
جماليات النسق الحر
هذا تنفرد به العربيه وكل اللغات التي وهي
قليله جدا في زمننا هذا
جماليات
النسق الحر يعطيك
من افاق البلاغه يعني في هذا النشق
تتضافر البلاغه مع النحو
ولكن دكتوره كانك تعزز التهمه الرائجه
العربيه بانها لغه ادب لغه جمال لغه شعر
وماذا في هذا شيء جميل لكن حينما نتحدث عن
اللغه الوظيفيه
الاقتصاديه التكنولوجيه نحن نتحدث عن
الانجليزيه كان الانجليزيه ايسر استعمالا
واكثر انتشار والدليل انتشاره هذا كلام
جميل جدا ودخل بنا في قلب القضيه ترى انا
موقعنا انا عاشق ومتيم ومتيم
لكنني اسال من باب فقط تمثيل لاني متابع
لك الله يحفظك
اللغه مستويات
ان شئت ان تاتي بها
على
التركيب
المعياري يسمونه
فهذا لك ان شئت ان
تلاعبها وتعابها وتعبر بها عن مكنون
المكنون فهذا لك اذا اللغه التي تعطيك
الخيارين
غير اللغه التي تعطيك الخيار الواحد
القضيه قضيه عنايتنا نحن
بلغتنا اذا هنا نتجه للمقاربتين الاخريين
مساله التربيه والتعليم والمقاربه الثالثه
التي طرحتها المجتمعيه والمقاربه
ودور السلطه ايضا يعني انا ذات يوم في
مقدمه اللي كتبتها لمعجم القراءات
القرانيه
لاخي الدكتور عبد اللطيف الخطيب الذي
تزاملنا معا في اعراب القران الكريم
مجلد نعم اعراب
بالتفصيل في اعراب ايه التنزيل في هذه
المقدمه قلت ان اللغه وحدها تستحق مؤتمر
قمه عربي المجامع اللغويه دكتور اينها
يعني من هذه القضيه الاشكاليه اللغه مساله
حضاريه وليست مساله يعني شكليه او سطحيه
او ثانويه هو المجامع اللغويه منذ نشاتها
قامت بدور كبير جدا جدا في رعايه اللغه
وفي حياطه اللغه وضمت مجموعه من الرواد
الاوائل الكبار سواء في المجمع العلمي في
دمشق او مجمع اللغه العربيه في القاهره او
المجمع العلم العراقي ولكن
اصابها ما اصاب المناخ العام يعني كانهم
مع تقدير للسن كل شخص كانها مجموعه من
الخارجين عن يعني الزمن عن التفاعلات على
المشهد ويتحدثون حديثا خاصا بهم ليسوا
متفاعلين بشكل اقصد المجامع كلها ليسوا
متفاعلين مع مع التحديات الكبيره هذا جزء
من مشكله المجامع اللغويه ايضا
والجزء الاخر انها
انشغلت بمشروعات كبيره جدا جدا
لكن
لم تحسن التاتي لكثير من هذه المشروعات
المجمع الليبي
نعم ليش مش المجمع المصري او المجمعه لا
هذا لا اسال عنه هذا الدكتور سعد مصنوع
عضوا في المجموعه اللغوي
انا اقول
والله انا اقول لك ذلك صادقا لا يعنيني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واقع الاسلامي يعج بعشرات الطرق الصوفيه
لكن عددا منها كتب له البروز اكثر من غيره
وتاتي في صدرتها طرق الشاذليه والقادريه
والتجاريه والخلوتيه والنقشبنديه وفي بلد
كبصر يتراوح اتباع الطرق الصوفيه بين عشره
وخمسه عشر مليون مريد اما في الجزائر
فيقدر مركز الدراسات والابحاث في جامعه
كيمبرج اعدادهم بنحو المليون ونصف المليون
مريد يقوم المنهج الصوفي على اسس عده منها
العوده الى الماضي واتباع السلف الصالح
قولا وفعلا والجد في العباده والتجرد من
الاهواء والرغبات الدنيويه املا في الشفاء
من اسقام النفس واوهام العقل وفقا للادبيه
الصوفيه
ورغم الانتشار الذي تحظى به الطرق الصوفيه
في العالم الاسلامي فانها لم تسلم من
حملات استندت الى ممارسات بعض المريدين
وطقوسهم الغريبه وتكررت الاتهامات لهم
بالجنون والانفصال عن الواقع بل وصل الامر
الى اطلاق اتهامات اخرى تقدح في عقيدتهم
محورنا الاخير يتحدث عن التصوف والصوفيه
والدكتور سعد ما الذي اتى بنا الى هذه
الضفه لديهن هذه النزعه
في حدود الدنيا وثمه تعمق اكبر في هذا
الامر هو التصوف حاله
اكثر منه
يعني عقيده
وهي معايشه
للنفس واستكشاف للعيوب واستكشاف للنتوءات
التي تظهر في حياتك ومحاوله التصفيه
والترقي لقد ورثت هذا
[موسيقى]
التوجه من والدي رحمه الله فقد كان يعني
متصوفا تصوفا حقا رحمه الله على ذكر
التصوف الحق ما بين تصوف الدروشه والتصوف
الطقوسي الذي بدا يعني ينتشر بشكل كبير
ومن بين التصوف كما اشرت له الحاله التجلي
والرغي والصفاء
والتعمق والتجذر في الاشياء كان كان هذا
الخط الرصين بدا يعني
يتلاشى فشيئا هو لا يتلاشى لكن دائما
الظواهر الصارخه
هي عاده التي تلفت النظر
يعني الذي يعايش حاله
في محاوله الاتصال مع الله ليس كالذي يحمل
البيرق ويدق الدفوف ويسير في الموالد هذا
الطبيعي جدا جدا يعني الظواهر
الصارخه هي التي
يعني تشرق الكاميرا كما كما يقولون لكن
التصوف لا يموت التصوف
اعتقد انه ربما كان الحل
لكثير من الصراعات الايدولوجيه
الدينيه
بين
بين الناس ارى يعني انا قابلت عده اشخاص
شخصيه مثقفه وبارزه في عده مجالات
وكان لديهم نزعه تصوف كاني رايت فيها رغبه
في معاشره لهم مؤخره في الانعزال الى حد
ما في الابتعاد عن منطقه الصراع التي
نعيشها بشكل دائم بين كل التيارات سواء
دينيه او سياسيه وكانها يعني خلاص او مخرج
او او ملجا لذات لا تؤمن بواقعها وبصراعات
صغيره يعني ينشغل بها الناس في كلامك بعض
الحق لكن
الصوفيه الحاقه تتجاوز ذلك
احدى وظائفها نعم تتجاوز ذلك بمنهج
التربيه والمربي والمريد
الامر لا الامر لا يكون حصيرا
داخل الذات انما هناك رجل
حباه الله من فضله
ويستطيع ان ينقل كثيرا ممن يتصلون به من
حاله
[موسيقى]
الانعزال الى حاله الاتصال
ولذلك ليس عجبا ان تجد هناك طرق صوفيه لا
اعني الطرق التي يعني
الشائعه انما التصوف تربيه
وهذه التربيه
تحول كثيرا
وتتجاوز كثيرا الذات المنفصله الذات
المنعزله ولكن يعني
الامر ليس سهله على اي طريقه يسير شيخنا
سعد مصلح
والله انا تجاذبتني
وهذا يدل على سعه افق
التصوف في ذاته
الوالد رحمه الله كان
اخذ العهد على شيخه في الطريق الخلواتيه
وقد عشت معه هذه المرحله بل انا كنت يعني
منشدا وانا صغير في في الحضره التي كانت
تقام حضره الذكر التي كانت تقام كنت انشد
وانا لي من العمر 12 عاما
وكان هذا عجيبا يعني
عشت هذه الفتره
يعني عاصرت الشيخ الشيخ الكبير
رضي الله عنه
واسمح لي ان اقول انه يعني مسح على راسي
وقال لوالدي سيكون لابنك شان
واعتقد في صميم من صميم قلبي اني اعيش
ببرقه هذه اللمسه الى الان اذا حتى الجانب
الطقوسي والجانب الشعائري في الموضوع انت
منخرط فيه
حاليا اتكلم طبعا هي كل الطريقه لها
مجموعه من الاوراد مجموعه من الممارسات
وهي ممارسات يعني اذا وجدت الرجل
يدعم انه صوفي
وينقى بنفسه عن الكتاب والسنه
فليس بصفه
يعني هكذا قال الوالد
حقائق له ارجوزه في
سلسله الطريق الخلوتي التي تبدا من النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم ثم بالامام عليه ثم
الحسن البصري ثم
يعني تتداعى السلسله الى الشيخ الذي هو
صاحب
صاحب الوقت قال في هذه الارجوزه حقائق
يعشى لدى ظهورها
فتم اتى البيوت من ظهورها وليس للصواب من
ابواب تطرقك السنه والكتاب فمن اتى السنه
والكتابه ابصر في نورهم الصواب اخشى الا
تنتهي الحلقه
فلا اجد نفسي الا منخرطا في في طريقتك يا
دكتور انا شاكر جدا
بوجودك
ومتمده الله ممتن جدا لوجودك شاكر لطفك
وسيعه صدرك الدكتور سعد مصلوح
الاكاديمي استاذ الانسانيات وعضو المجمع
اللغوي ايضا الليبي شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
شكرا جزيلا سيدي شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام
انتم على طيب المتابعه في الاسبوع المقبل
ان شاء الله لنا اللقاء يتجدد في المقابله
دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
وتفقت امضي والنوازل ترتمي مسعوره
وغذاءهن دمائي
امضي ومن حولي ترف اجاكر دي جت لهن ملاحم
الورقاء واذا بنفسي بعد طول تكدر تصفو
وتسخر من جحيم عنائي
وتزاحم الاشواك في فجواتها بازائر ضفافه
الانداء
والصابى تمزجه بشهد رضابها والليله تخلقه
بفجر ضياء كان الصباح قد الهم لناظري
والان
فاستضى مسائي